avec nous Philippe Gachon il est
professeur de climatologie au
département géographique du calme
monsieur garchon bonsoir
monsieur garchon
à peu près dire la même chose là que
c'est exceptionnel que le une partie du
Québec est reçu comme ça l'équivalent
d'un mois de pluie en 36 heures vous
est-ce que ça vous a surpris
certainement les quantités sont
impressionnantes vous venez de le
mentionner mais je pense que ce qui a ce
qui a surtout été un des problèmes
pendant cet événement là c'est les
intensités horaires en fait on a eu
plusieurs événements d'ailleurs moi
j'habite à monter régie on l'a vu
d'ailleurs ce matin on est des séquences
depuis pratiquement continue mais
surtout avec des intensités extrêmement
fortes sur des périodes de temps
extrêmement courts et ça c'est
problématique parce que ça engendrer
évidemment la les inondations
extrêmement rapides qu'on a vu dans
certains secteurs et c'est ce problème
là qui va nous qui va on va dire nous
préoccuper en particulier dans le futur
avec le réchauffement climatique c'est
pas tellement les intensités sur les
longues périodes de temps mais sur les
couper de temps parce que c'est elle qui
sont responsables justement des
inondations avec des dommages qu'on voit
effectivement non seulement sur les
routes les ponts et la montée très très
rapide au niveau d'eau parce que le sol
est pas capable d'absorber cette
quantité qui arrive de façon très
intense comme vous dites
exactement les systèmes d'égouts aussi
n'absor pas en ville donc c'est un
problème les fausses intensités sur les
périodes de temps extrêmement courtes ça
pose tout un enjeu évidemment pour le
design d'infrastructure urbaine mais
aussi même on le voit ici dans le dans
les zones urbaines en fait rurales parce
que c'est les quantités qui sont énormes
qu'on ne voit pas normalement sur des
dans nos régions comme nous on voit
beaucoup plus au sud dans les horizons
tropicales en raison de mousson mais pas
dans nos régions à nous et avec le
réchauffement c'est ce qui nous c'est ce
qui va nous en fait nous affecter de
plus en plus donc cette intensité c'est
ça qui est préoccupe mais qu'est-ce qui
explique une telle intensité monsieur
Gachon
alors il y a plusieurs facteurs on a vu
les systèmes s'enchaîner un peu les uns
les uns par rapport aux autres il y en a
eu un surtout qui est plusieurs en fait
qui se sont formés le long de la côte
est en ce moment ce qui est préoccupant
c'est que si on a un Atlantique qui est
plus chaud que d'habitude non seulement
les os du goal stream les eaux chaudes
stream elles sont présentes mais le long
de la côte est justement au sud de
l'État de New York en justement des eaux
qui sont plus chauds que d'habitude donc
quand les systèmes météorologiques
arrivent sur ces eaux chaudes plus
d'évaporation plus humide dans
l'atmosphère ça peut se transférer moins
intensités de plus importantes c'est ce
qu'on a vu en particulier est-ce que
vous appelez ça ou si une rivière
atmosphérique c'est un terme qu'on
commence à entendre de plus en plus
absolument plus la température de l'eau
augmente plus l'évaporation
efficace rapide intense donc plus ça
peut humidifier l'atmosphère surtout
quand encore une fois le système arrive
au dessus de l'eau qui est chaude et en
particulier l'autre est fait aussi c'est
qu'on a la baie du son dans le Nord qui
a un espèce de creux atmosphérique qui a
favorisé justement une direction notre
précipitation les plus grandes quantités
de précipitations étaient pratiquement
dans ce depuis l'État de New York
jusqu'en direction de la Mauricie
d'ailleurs Charlevoix aussi a eu des
bonnes quantités mais l'esprit aussi a
beaucoup été affecté à un charbot qu'on
reçu plus de 120 mm en l'espace
effectivement d'un peu moins 48 heures
donc je vous ai présenté monsieur Gachon
comme professeur de climatologie vous
êtes aussi directeur général du réseau
inondation intersectionnelle du
sectorielle pardon du Québec
comment les gouvernements comment la
population doivent maintenant se
préparer à ce genre de phénomène
d'abord première des choses et
j'encourage les autorités à le faire
c'est tirer les leçons apprises de
l'événement est-ce que cet élément-là on
a bien vu en termes de prévision et si
c'est un événement exceptionnel comment
mieux se préparer c'est un peu la
question et je pense qu'au Québec on les
infrastructures qu'on doit revoir de
toute façon la plupart ont été
construits dans les années 60-70 au
moment où on ne parlait pas changement
climatique et surtout travailler en
amont
meilleures connaissance développement
des outils préparation prévention c'est
le nerf de la guerre d'ailleurs l'ONU
sortait un rapport aujourd'hui sur la
réduction des risques de désastre notre
capacité de résilience et il insiste
là-dessus il faut absolument travailler
en amont sensibilisé éduquer faire le
suivi des conditions qui sont en train
évidemment la rapidité avec laquelle le
changement climatique est en train de
s'opérer et voir dans la phase de
rétablissement une fois qu'évidemment
les événements sont passés à
reconstruire différemment parce que
définitivement on n'a pas les
infrastructures qui sont adaptées à des
changements aussi rapides aussi intense
et surtout aussi irrémédiable le
changement climatique est là pour rester
donc on disait en début d'entrevue
est-ce que c'est exceptionnel ou pas
peut-être que ça va devenir de moins en
moins exceptionnel monsieur Gachon aussi
c'est des événements là on commence à
s'y habituer
absolument les statistiques passées sont
en train d'être justement dépassé donc
d'abord il faut analyser ces phénomènes
là est-ce qu'ils sont exceptionnels
est-ce qu'on peut les attribuer au
changement climatique ça c'est un des
choses qu'il faut faire et regarder
aussi dans le futur avec les outils de
plus en plus développés en terme de
bonsilisation voir comment ces
événements particulièrement intense sur
les durées très courtes vont évoluer
parce que c'est ça les gens enjeux
surtout encore une fois vis-à-vis des
infrastructures et vis-à-vis aussi la
sécurité des personnes pour bien se
préparer il faut évidemment avoir une
bonne connaissance de ces phénomènes là
et pouvoir mieux les prévoir dans le
futur et donc être capable de
s'améliorer entre autres
climatologie ou département de
géographie de Lucas merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
Merci à VOUS bonne fin de journée au
revoir